hello and good morning everyone welcome
to another episode of alexa and friends
my name
is jeff blankenberg uh and as we do
every week i get to bring an interesting
guest on from the world of alexa
to talk about all the things they're
working on where they came from
uh and the future so uh i want to
welcome arya rastro
uh welcome to the show aria
oh you are uh you might be muted
yes there we go welcome thank you
yeah good morning good afternoon good
evening everyone
um i'm mario rostro i'm a senior
principal
at amazon and alexa and i'm happy and
excited to be here
and i hope everyone enjoys this this
session i think they will uh
so one of the things that i like to do
is we start these conversations
is to ask you a couple of silly
questions and i haven't prepared you for
these questions you may not know what
they are
so uh although i have found that
previous guests have gone back and
watched previous episodes to try to
figure out what might be coming
so the first question i like to ask
people especially uh you know we for the
last 10 or so years we've had some
amazing superhero movies that have come
out in theaters
and one of the things that i always like
to ask people is uh if you could pick
any one superpower for yourself
what would you pick a superpower for me
um i think if i were to
pick a superpower would be the ability
to read people's mind
that's a good one and so my follow-up
question that then of course is
why why why why that one um
i i mean there i think there are yeah
multiple reasons but
first of all it would be very fun oh
yeah like if you're the only one that
that have that superpower
it could be good or bad right
yeah i mean that's right you you know a
lot who are your friends or you're
not there are a lot of things about that
um
and uh the other part of it is that i i
love human interactions
i love human interaction and i'm i love
getting you know
you know working people uh uh um
uh you know on different levels so i
think having the ability
to read people's mind would give me a
superpower in terms of like building
you know trust and attraction like those
interactions more meaningful
and you know be able to to uh
to act quicker in in in interesting
situations and opportunities situations
yeah
right yeah i think that makes sense i
mean being able to read people's minds
has a lot of powers and i think it would
benefit
anyone greatly um but yeah i can i can
definitely see that all right so that
was my first question second one
uh it takes a little storytelling um but
i want you to imagine
i know you and i are actually both in
seattle right now we're just not in the
same room
uh but as you think about walking down
the streets of seattle
um there's a lot of very large buildings
right and to walk around one of those
buildings can take a little while
uh and you're trying to meet a friend at
a restaurant and you know that it's just
on the other side of this block and
there's a
there's a convenient alley that you
could go through that would take you
right to the place you want to go
now it's a brightly lit day there's
nothing to be concerned about there's
not
you're not worried about crime per se so
you decide you're going to cut down this
alley
to meet your friends at this restaurant
and as you get about halfway down the
alley
you notice that the end that you're
heading towards emerges a giant
horse-sized duck really large duck right
and uh it looks a little aggressive it
doesn't look friendly and so as
as any smart human would do you turn
around decide to go back the way you
came
only to realize that that end has been
closed in by a
hundred horse-sized i'm sorry duck-sized
horses
so a bunch of very small horses they too
look a little aggressive
and so uh you are now trapped in this
alley between these two
choices and you know that you're
probably gonna have a small
scuffle a fight trying to get out of one
of these two
uh ends which end do you choose which
end do i choose
um right it depends on the wrist of the
alley
can i can i'm not very wide you're not
you're not just gonna run around not
able to side and step that one
no okay some people have attempted to
slide like
underneath it maybe but
that's up to you right i wish i could
walk one of those
i mean the the single dog to walk with
you know to talk the other dogs through
that like let me give me a little bit of
a slack
you know you're a master negotiator i
like it yes
that's how i tell i tell you i love
interactions i love
doing things you know by working work
working them through
you know and you know and and you know
removing the burdens and contentions in
indian attractions to be able to
to converge so so i've heard
like i've asked this question to 50 or
so people at this point
that is the first time i've heard about
negotiation i liked it
we'll try to mediate uh the ducks and
the horses and we'll see how it all
works out in the end
exactly uh very interesting approach i
like that it i think it's telling it it
shows a little bit about who you are and
how you think about solving problems
so uh so thank you for humoring me with
my silly questions
uh the next step uh the next thing that
i'd really love to
chat with you about is kind of where you
came from uh i mean you you mentioned
your title at the beginning and we'll
certainly get in more into
what you do here at amazon today but i
always like to give people the journey
and for our audience this is often their
favorite part of the conversation
um i love to hear about where you came
from where you went to school where you
grew up
um if that's important and any of the
kind of major milestones that you saw in
your career as you changed roles or
changed companies and how those had a
formative path to where you are today
yeah so i was born and raised in iran
and
um it wasn't until i was about 21 22
that i
moved to the states uh to do my phd
and um so you went to college in iran as
well
yeah i did my undergrad and then i i
mean started applying to
to phd schools here in the us and i got
admitted to johns hopkins university and
i
started my phd back in 2006 i want to
say yep
okay and um you know during my undergrad
i majored in electrical engineering
and uh i actually got very interested in
learning about signal processing
you know probability theory and you know
statistics
and uh in fact actually towards the end
of my
undergrad i got actually uh the
opportunity to learn about information
theory and i started getting some you
know taking some grad
school uh uh grad level uh courses in
information theory
which uh which is the bread and butter
of everything communication today
you know um and um
and and actually in fact there we can
talk about a little bit if you wanted to
there are some synergy very
nice synergies between information
theory and machine learning as
the current form but i didn't really
know about machine learning and ai per
se
during my undergrad and it wasn't until
when i started my phd
in 2006 i joined at the center for
language and speech processing
where i got the opportunity to work with
fred gellardick who is known as one of
the pioneers in the
statistic called the speech recognition
people actually
refer to him as as the father of modern
speech recognition
and um fred had had a huge impact on my
you know in in shaping my my you know
career path and also like my my interest
in
in speech recognition and uh and ml and
ai in general
and one one funny fact was that one it
turned out that
uh fred and i had one thing in common
which is fred was also by heart and
information theories
in fact he was a he was advised by
robert robert
fano that he is a super famous you know
information theories
who was actually had had done a lot of
collaboration with claude shannon
the infamous anna that everybody knows
that he was a
pioneer and you know who wrote that very
famous paper about you know
channel capacity and information theory
that changes a lot of things in the
field so that that that was interesting
so when fred called me
i remember vividly that day and i got
admitted he once said like i want to
talk to you like see if you're
interested in
speech recognition information to your
intellect said like
fred you're you got me there um i
i know you i would love to work with you
and that though like it was a half an
hour
you know talk a call right yeah and it
was an easy choice for me
on the other hand like the other
opportunity that i had was that
our lab center for language and speech
processing was was a multi-disciplinary
lab like there were people from computer
science
from computational linguistics from
electrical engineering with different
diverse set of
skills and backgrounds which actually
helped me a lot into understanding
a lot of you know different concepts
like take it from the signal process
that i already had known a little bit
about
undergrad and then doing starting doing
the speech recognition i had one of the
like i'm a few of the best people in the
speech recognition field around me there
were a few
well-known officers that i worked with
including fred himself
and and and on the other hand since i
was an electrical engineering
but i'm the major in electrical
engineering i
wasn't really too experienced didn't
know much about computer science so
getting exposed to computer science
folks around me in the lab actually
helped me shape a lot of things in terms
of
thinking about algorithms data
structures in an abstract way
things that eventually become a tool set
powerful tool set for me to be able to
apply them into
to speech recognition and ml problems
and you know by the time i joined alexa
in 2012 after i finished my phd i
um i mean latching onto my background in
the speech recognition
i started with a you know few folks
on the engineering side and and other
researchers we started building this
picture recognition technology from
ground up
and and
also because those early days when alexa
was using infancy and it was a secret
project
the team was very small so the
opportunity there for me was that i got
to expose to
many aspects of you know designing the
whole alexa end-to-end
on the architectural level on the asr
natural language understanding component
and other components that are involved
the in the whole
execution pipeline and then it gave me
the opportunity to be exposed to this
and then
eventually i got also interested besides
asr interested in the
natural language understanding and then
the conversational ai aspect
those are some of the you know
interesting problems and tech uh
technical problems that we are today
working on
that's amazing so so you got in very
very early on the alexa stuff
uh 2012 i mean that that's three years
before the device the first echo
launched
exactly uh that's amazing so do you have
any uh
you know without revealing any secrets
or anything are there any kind of fun or
interesting stories that you have from
those early days
uh those early days yes i can tell you
one final story actually i mean it's a
funny and interesting
uh in different ways um so when we
started actually working on a speech
recognition
uh for alexa some of you know like the
thing that we'll have to do was
uh call it's called far field of speech
recognition which
is like we had to which is which is a
you know
solving father is paramount for getting
you know alexa successful this is very
different at that time
people i mean using cell phones like a
smartphone
was becoming widespread people started
using some voice interfaces in terms of
doing voice search
but the difference was that in the phone
you reach out to your phone you bring it
very close to your
to your to your to your face and start
talking
in for for uh for
for as for for following speech
recognition per se
it was a different i mean the the
challenge was very different
we had to design a speech recognition
such that like you could put your device
like 30
feet away from you maybe there is a tv
or background noise
in your house and it was paramount for
us to make sure that the speech
recognition
in the context of far-fetched speakers
is very accurate and low latency so the
funniest story
is that early days we had a we we we
essentially created an advisory board
like very famous uh
professors and researchers that are
working on you know
speech recognition problem of course
alexa was secret we couldn't tell them
what we are working on but the goal was
that like every so often we have some
sort of meetings with them we ask
questions
uh uh without revealing what we are
working on
funny thing is that this folks didn't
know what we were working on but
one of the things that early on then
emphasized on us is that guys
with respect to speech recognition
whatever problem you're trying to solve
and work on
make sure that you don't that you don't
work on far field and speech recognition
far field special recognition is
inherently
very super challenging problems and one
that is not solved yet and we don't have
solutions for it
so yeah so you can imagine early on
restarting getting that feedback but you
know
nice thing is that you know we didn't
shy away
and yeah we were excited to to to work
on that problem and eventually come up
with a solution that we could go
uh uh launch echo with that that's great
and so
without without revealing anything that
we can't reveal
what was there was there a trick was
there was there something that
like a switch that we flipped that we
were like oh my gosh now far field is so
much better because of
x y or z are there is that something we
can talk about
um we can talk about a little bit uh
about the things that we did that now by
by now
they're there are known to people okay
so
in a sense we were lucky that when we
started uh there were there
this revolution uh in the mlai and a
speech recognition per specific it was
happening in terms of using
deep neural networks it turned out that
the same time around 2011
2012 people started looking into you
know new techniques of applying the
neural networks into 2-2 to a speech
recognition task
and people have started showing that at
least on some of the benchmarks that
this is resulting in a in a huge you
know improvement
on the task that was known at that time
but but like we said like most of those
stacks were
closed stock not not far field so
so that's so that's part of history we
doubled down early on
and that was a that was a good
investment in building the
infrastructure around
you know building deep neural network
technology in terms of
infrastructures algorithm and using also
back-end aws
because it turned out deep neural
networks are very compute heavy
they they thrive from data and compute
and i think you know the confluence of
these three things
right getting a start you know starting
on uh work on deep neural network very
early on betting on them
you know having the aws backhand and
infrastructure
as they as the white matter if you wish
of
of
of our background and then uh you know
um
making sure i mean uh that that we uh
put a lot of effort into
leveraging super was an unsupervised
techniques
to you know to to apply those diploma
networks was a recipe
for for building far field special
recognition of course i'm very
simplifying this problem there of course
there's so many so many technical
problems uh on the way that we had to
solve them
yeah and and i honestly feel like
for for a lot of businesses uh and
certainly some of the
the science and technology that we're
seeing with alexa um
things like aws just a relatively
infinite amount of compute and storage
is
i think that unlocks so many different
things especially in the research world
where before that was that was a hard
problem to solve is like
where are we going to store all this
data or how are we going to process this
in a reasonable cost-effective way
i mean i remember when i was in college
which was in the mid 90s
the the server farms that they had just
to crunch numbers were it was just
amazing
absolutely and now you can go to a
website and just plug some numbers in
and go
absolutely it's amazing amazing um
all right so so here's a good question
uh so you you
got your phd uh you got right out of
school you joined alexa
um but you've been here you've been here
a while now
uh and obviously you you've moved up the
ranks a bit but
what what drew you to amazon what and
certainly what's keeping you here now
i asked that as an amazon employee so i
you know what keeps me here i like uh i
like the company i like the culture
but i would love to hear more about um
kind of your perspective on that
yeah and that's a great question uh this
is a one that i get
quite often because now i just marked my
nine year anniversary at alex and slash
amazon
i actually even internally i get that
question what keeps you here but let me
start with what
got me excited to join first uh so when
i like
i mentioned when i finished my phd i was
quite convinced that
you know uh voice interface interfaces
are gonna revolutionize how we
interact with computers
and back-end services i was quite
convinced about that
at the same time working on the speech
recognition technology i was i
knew that this is a challenging and a
complex tag
so one that like mid size and you know
smaller size companies cannot
it would not be able to uh build from
ground up
so i was quite convinced that when i did
the interview
i mean uh alexa folks and didn't didn't
reveal it to me that yo you're going to
work on alexa
right i knew it was asr and speech
related but i didn't know the exact
you know the exact project but i
convinced myself that this has to do
with like you know
amazon given aws infrastructure and all
the nice things about tools on aws
is going to be working on something that
would become speech services
for you know both on the consumer and
business side that like you will
federate and
commercialize and you know if you wish
speech recognition services so that
everybody can can use it in in in their
services
uh little i know that i the first day i
joined i was exposed to this
ugly cylinder back then prototype
version one
that i was told that you need to make
this short short that like when you talk
to this device from 30 feet away
it's going to recognize you very well
accurately with low latency
and the first thing is so it doesn't
have a display most of the time like
when you do special punch on your phone
you see like there's a feedback
like right right feedback you see the
recognition output so
in case things are not working very well
you quickly can recover
you can't you have your touch you can do
you can fall back to other mechanism
to fulfill your request say yes there's
no display speech recognition has to
work
almost with 100 accuracy okay let's do
it
and by the way yeah on the on the speech
services i wasn't also too off
it turned out a few years later aws and
us we worked separately on on on
building speech services
and enabling others something that later
become you know
people with no uh aws transcript service
at the same time i was always on a avid
amazon customer
so by that time i had already you know
uh you know uh bought and ordered many
books
through amazon funny fact fun fact is
that the very first item i had ordered
on amazon.com back in 2006 when i i got
here and started my phd
was a book called the statistical method
for speech recognition
which was written by my advisor oh my
gosh yes
uh a bit uh in a sense i had to
read that book otherwise it would fit
the whole purpose
so but i always so that that that part
i mean this whole magic of ordering
online through
you know uh and getting everything on
time it was super magical
for me and then i was always amazed by
the customer
uh you know uh focused company like like
amazon so
that was another reason that uh i i
convinced myself that i want to
take this risk i don't know the project
but i want to
be part of an amazing customer focused
company
and potentially work on something that
can delight millions of millions of
customers yeah
um with respect to with regards to your
question about what keeps me excited
here you know
uh i i alluded to this you know uh
working on real
real world problems uh and
and working backward from customer needs
and pain
it is super exciting and super you know
uh uh
uh uh interesting for for for
as a scientist and at the same time
um there are a lot there's still a lot
of challenges remain within the speech
recognition you know field
ai in general and conversational ai
specifically
uh so you know building i mean
keep improving our low latency speech
recognition and serving billions of
billions of interactions per week
and like you know building this
federated voice interfaces for our
developers to be able to
build on top of the build new use cases
and skills and
scenarios for our customers it is
technically
challenging but it's very uh you know uh
very very exciting and and
uh perhaps uh
uh sorry i thought i got i thought i got
logged out
um and uh and then now i mean
yeah i mean i think you you touched
based on this but with nico a little bit
last week
now you're actually working on making
alexa even more conversational and
natural
in terms of like we announce uh you know
turn taking approaches
you know where we alleviate the need
from the customers to to say the wake
word with each interaction
so they can you know in a very natural
way barging
and uh you know start a request with
alexa they don't even have to say
alexa do that to me do that for me they
can just say
turn on the light or order that one you
know so without saying
it's very way more natural than
conversational so
those are the you know so the bottom
line is that the
the the the challenging uh uh
technically challenging problems is
still there
and i'm quite excited to to to be part
of the company that is
delighting our customers through solving
those challenging problems
yeah so i mean as we talk about
difficult
problems i mean i think that for years
uh
even something which is it feels
relatively solved anymore right asr
uh automated speech recognition
it it's it still seems like there's
there's probably
more to be done there but i think a lot
of people look at that as like oh we're
done we we've solved that problem
what's your perspective on that uh it's
a great question we have come a long way
in in getting speech recognition
technology to the point that is
you know widespread ubiquitous in in
many aspects of our lives
that that granted we should we
you know we should celebrate that fact
yes
there are a lot of challenges we made so
i can i mean i can talk about from few
things
specifically for speech recognition that
uh i think personally it starts starts
challenging an interesting problem one
of the things has to do with the
multilingual and
code switching so so it turns out like
in
in markets like india customers are very
creative
and in you know mixing you know hindi
with english
and that puts a huge burden in terms of
the
challenge and the complexity on the
speech recognition
so um i'm solving the code switching
problem humans are really good once you
know those two languages
you're really good on recognizing you
know the
uh the mix of the languages yeah where
they happen so we are good at that
uh turns out machines are still having
tough time recognizing some of these
creative ways that people
mix languages and for for for markets
like india this is this is essential
because otherwise you will not have a
good customer experience for for
fulfilling their their request
the other aspect of this is you know
there's still like challenges in terms
of you know
making a speech recognition accuracy
robustness
great for noisy and very challenging
scenarios
you know alexa and voice assistants are
becoming more prevalent
outside of our home use cases and
they're they're using them on the go
where you're you know you're you're
situated in noisy environments
and it turns out that uh we still have
some
some work to do to make sure that the
speech recognition is robust
in these scenarios like um
the other aspect of this is that uh
the i mean think about alexa
and in multi-party scenarios where
like two to a speakers at the same time
they're talking to each other but
they're also like actively
uh uh uh you know are having uh alexa
participate in their conversation
yeah multi-speaker party scenarios put
put a put an extra challenge into us on
a special coordination often
uh and then you have multi-speaker
scenarios people have overlapping speech
you know there's crosstalk you know it's
not really like
like i'm i'm work i'm talking to my legs
only so i'm very
clear-cut in terms of the boundary and
the segments of my speech
people do you know do do do talk over
each other
and that overlap is speech and multi
multi-speaker scenarios put actually
extra burden and challenge for for
speech recognition and
signal processing per se there are other
things that also like you know we have
come a long way
in building you know efficient learning
algorithms that can learn both from
supervised and unsupervised data
i think you talked with anika about this
that how we use millions of hours of
unsupervised data to to to improve their
uh asr record recognition without having
to they need to have the
the human labels or transcriptions right
so that's one aspect of it but the other
part is that we're still doing some of
the most of these things in offline
you know bringing those algorithms into
an incremental and lifelong
lifelong learning it's yet another step
that we have to take like it turns out
humans
we learn on the fly through our
interactions with
each other and environment we keep
learning
and updating our beliefs and you know
both on the perceptions
like vision and especially recognition
if you would also on the on the higher
levels semantic
and you know understanding the intent or
or
entities right we keep you keep learning
so that's another thing so now that's
another challenge that
how do you make sure that alexa is
is capable of you know doing the
learning on the fly
and then by the way there you have a lot
of like implicit and explicit signals
so it turns out in the multi-turn and
like as customers actually interact with
alexa we do have implicit signals to
know that if asr and speech recognition
natural language understanding
was successful in recognizing the speech
and intent
or like for example you you would start
a query with alexa right away so
like alexa stopped so that perhaps is a
big signal to tell you that there was
something wrong
in terms of either misrecognition or
execution
with respect to the to the previous turn
so how do you use those
vic signals in multi-turn and dialogue
and an execution to
to to bring this flywheel into a like a
lifelong and incremental learning
um right and uh the other aspect of this
is of course uh uh multimodal so uh
how do you how do we use like humans are
really good
at like you and i when i when we talk in
terms of turn taking
to know if it's your time to talk or if
it's my time to talk
we use a lot of clues i mean from a
speech side and also we use
vision clues like i i'm seeing you i
know when you're about to
you know inject yourself into a
conversation
right and that that so and also
from the visual clues i mean in
conjunction with the speed
also know when you're about to finish
your turn so both in terms of
understanding when you are about to say
something
or when you finish there is a lot of
signal in
in terms of a multi-modal i mean fusion
between vision and signal so yeah i
think a lot of people probably see that
if you think about the pandemic and the
fact that we've all been on video calls
for the last
year or so it's it's really clear to a
lot of people that
it's much harder to participate in a
conversation when
people aren't aware of what you're doing
especially if it's an audio only call
it's hard to interject yourself it's
hard to contribute to the conversation
and interrupt because they don't know
that that's coming where when you and i
are talking in person it's so much more
easy and obvious
yeah and perhaps one more thing that
yeah excellent point and one more thing
that i add is also like since you've
been brought up brought up covered and i
mean
you know there is this also notion uh
the challenge in the speech recognition
that
new terms and phrases and vocabulary
is is always being added to our to our
dictionary so i mean back in
march 2020 we didn't know about covet 19
as
a word as a workout as a phrase so and
it's paramount for us to be able to
capture those trends
like from from web or other external
sources and to be able to
inject those into our speech recognition
system because people started actually
asking about coping time t
what are symptoms about when my team and
if you cannot build a system that can
quickly capture those trends
and add them into the speech recognition
system
you fail yeah so that's another aspect
yeah and even beyond big events like
covid i mean there's
just the the generation of slang that
gets created and
the new definitions for words i i know
i'm going to sound like an old dad now
but
you know when you when you hear kids
talk today a lot of times they'll say
instead of saying i'm not lying or i'm
i'm not kidding they'll use the phrase
no cap
which is a i don't know where it came
from but the the idea that they say that
that is now a new phrase that is being
used to mean
i'm not lying uh or this is the truth
and uh it's it's just really interesting
to me to think about how the engine
behind the scenes has to start being
able to
recognize and interpret those things uh
in context to be able to say oh
this is actually what they mean by that
absolutely we definitely
uh been we have invested a lot of effort
and
still going on into making sure that
you're nimble and agile enough
latching onto the learning algorithms
that we have
to to capture those trends new phrasing
new vocabularies
so you mentioned nico earlier uh but i
talked with nicostrom
uh last month and we were talking a lot
about on-device asr automatics
automated speech recognition and some of
the implications that has for our
customers
uh and i know this is something that you
use also uh so i'd love to know can you
can you tell me more about
kind of the onboard asr i know you
hinted at it earlier but i'd love to
know more about that
yeah so so it turns out that um
like we talked about that you know
having a reliable
and low latency and fast speech
recognition is essential
for building the customer experience
around
on the conversation on ai and
customers do expect that even if their
network is choppy
low bandwidth the speech recognition is
so fast and if you don't i mean
like in the speech recognition when we i
mean specifically for alexa when
when a blackboard is uh spoken on the we
detected on it
on device and conventionally you start
streaming the audio
to cloud to to implement and execute
a speech recognition so it turns out
that we have to send these uh audio
frames and signal
uh through the network and some like i
said sometimes the network is choppy
you might your your wireless might your
network might be you know out of reach
still they have to make sure that the
speech recognition works fast and
reliably
so one of the recent trends
like past year uh last last two years in
a speech recognition
is to move away from conventional
method uh cloud-based speech recognition
systems that
essentially encode acoustic model and
language model
acoustic model is a is a component that
like understands acoustic closing the
signal
and tries to match them to phonemes and
words language model is a component that
understands so
what are the sequence of words that are
likely to be spoken to a device
right so conventionally we use these two
knowledge sources you know this joint
and separately
in a speech recognition cloud uh
cloud-based speech recognition
to to to to to implement this feature
application
so now with the ad advances
in neural network and end-to-end
approaches
we we have built systems that are
capable of uh doing a speech recognition
using the one unified
deep neural network which encodes both
language mode and acoustic model
jointly they both are jointly encoded in
the network
and these networks are capable of
directly mapping and translating audio
uh into sequence of words there's
nice properties and attributes that you
gain through using these new techniques
one
is that because you you have a system
which is
joint jointly trained language model and
acoustic model
you get far better compression and
throughput per size meaning that if you
were to design your speech recognition
for a given size
and a given memory size your accuracy
would be far better than the
conventional system this is especially
uh important for constrained scenarios
like agents and
on device where you don't have a lot of
memory
or your compute power is more restricted
in comparison with cloud so it's
latching onto these new techniques we
are able to build special cognition
system that are
far better in terms of accuracy given
those those constrained
the other benefit of getting uh that we
are achieving by
using this end-to-end uh one neural
network uh
approach to to to solve the speech
recognition is that
we can apply well-known sparsification
and compression techniques
uniformly to the model so besides the
fact that the model inherently has a
better
compress like you know compression uh uh
abilities
uh we can further downsize the model
without losing accuracy uh
to to to to even make the the footprint
of the model the smaller and make them
even more appropriate for for for
constrained and challenging scenarios
um so the so these are end-to-end but
besides that we also like
i mean this year at icast we presented
the paper that
we have actually applied you know higher
level
architecture changes to the speech
recognition to make it
even more low latency and more efficient
the end-to-end system so one of the
things that
uh in a speech recognition actually for
voice assistant we do today is that
like i said so when you say the wake
word alexa
you detect that on on device and
by the time we detect we are behind
because the customer already has set the
red board right
right so now we start sending it to the
to the downstream which is a speech
recognition and
started streaming the audio to recognize
that the subsequent uh
you know uh the the frames and words
but for privacy and efficiency reasons
they actually go back and reprocess that
record segment
in the speech recognition so this is to
make sure that
there are some sometimes rare events
where the wakeboard on device record has
as false false accepts we want to make
sure that the asr which is a much larger
model much
uh you know higher accuracy mode in
terms of recognizing general
speech is recognizing and reprocessing
that backward to make sure that we get a
second estate signal that
liquid was really a spoken there yeah
but on the other hand
this puts us in a tough path uh toughest
spot because we have to go back in time
we have a backlog so we already have
some sort of a latency that we have to
catch up with because
like waypoint in general is the average
is one second we are one second behind
uh with respect to the to the spoken
signal so one of the things that we
presented in our class we
leveraged this you know uh knowing that
the wake word was a spoken and we inject
the topology in the neural network where
it says like we know that the
wake word is usually off of a higher
signal to noise ratio because people to
get their attention off their devices
they usually louder
more clear because like even when i talk
to you to get your attention
i i latch on to some you know clues i
mean i mean give you something
you know strengthen my signal to to get
your attention so
and so we know that it's lower
perplexity like it's not as challenging
compared to the to the rest of the
signal so we leverage that
and we define like you know different
branches in our speech recognition
neural network which says like
if i'm processing the vapor segment
let's do it with a much smaller branch
in the network
because we know it's low perplexity is
cleaner signal
why to spend a lot of compute so
and then one by the time we move to the
to the intent full segment
we we use our full full-blown uh higher
capacity
higher compute uh branches of the
network in fact we actually
is beyond backward we generalize this
method and we're actually going to
present it
interest speech 2021 where we say look
it's not only about the weak word versus
the rest of the
the rest of the you know audio if you
think about it
there are intermediate pauses in the
signal intermediate pulses are not that
challenging there there's not really
much of a signal into it so why to
you know vase compute and power into
processing them
so in other words conventionally when
you
when you come up with a with a fix with
a compression
and a size in your model you design it
in a static and fixed
way meaning every single frame that
comes into a speech recognition is going
to be
processed using the same level of
compute
and and processing power we find that
this is deficient we don't we can't
really actually be smarter than that
because when you when you want to go
with the compression rates that are
very very extreme for edge cases
doing this compression static will put
you in a very tough position in terms of
the trade-off between
speed computing latency and accuracy so
into
i mean we have a paper in intro speech
2021 where
we actually create a general neural
network that
comprises of you know slow and fast
branches
and uh what we do is that we teach that
network
to learn inherent uh closing the signal
to
to know that where it makes sense to
spend more compute
very with it where it's okay to to to
use a much much faster branch of the
network
and do the processing faster um
so we are presenting that uh in
intersewish 2001 and
that's one of the words i'm quite
excited about uh
and um so
and and i also talked about a little bit
that uh besides this high level
architecture we do have uh we presented
the work at icast this year that
talks about new methods of how to apply
better compression as far as
sparsification mechanism
to to to to our deep neural network and
uh we actually uh presented the word
where we use
some of the posts on the on the call
might know uh compress
uh sensing algorithm algorithms to
to to to achieve better uh
compressions rates in the speech
recognition so compress sensing
algorithm is a signal processing it's a
well-known tool
in signal processing community which is
to reconstruct a signal and use some
redundancy in the signal with a much
lower
uh you know
dimensions and a much lower lower
compute so we
use that and apply that to deep neural
network techniques to
to learn uh you know uh sparse sparse
models that actually resulted in
in in a in a good amount of improvement
in terms of the compute and latency
wow that is uh that is super interesting
to think about how
how that all works um all right so one
one of the other things that
uh you've written about is the idea
between like blurring the boundaries
between acoustic processing
and language understanding can you talk
more about how
you know asr is evolving around that
yeah uh that's right last year
uh i think for i cast my interest speech
i wrote a blog about this
and i think it was broadcast so
i mean we know now of more efficient
algorithms that are available to us as
scientists and engineers
and so now it has become apparent that
asr is not just about focusing on speech
of a particular turn so conventionally
we would treat these turns like in a
dialogue
as isolated and we just try to like do a
speech recognition given the acoustic
information in the term right the
human brain doesn't really rely
exclusively
on acoustics to do a speech recognition
they do really
do use a balance of you know acoustic
perception
and also semantically fill information
to be able to
to to to carry the speech recognition to
us and
so so he so we want the machines
also so be like that let me give you an
example so if you're sitting in a bar
so if i you're not talking in in an
environment which is super super clean
we are able to carry the you know
recognition of the phonemes and words in
a very high resolution
using using acoustic signal now imagine
scenario you're sitting in a bar
super noisy and we are very good and you
know
latching on to the to the information
which is encoded in our context and the
topic
that is evolving over the conversation
and use
that to make our ability to recognize
each other as a speech better despite
the fact that
the environment is noisy yeah so i i can
actually relate to this i
uh like i said i'm here in seattle and i
had a team meeting last night and we
it was a happy hour after work and we
met at a bar
and i was speaking with someone um in a
very noisy environment but on top of
that
uh english wasn't their first language
right so
they were speaking english but it was
with their accent um
and what i found oh goodness uh there's
always
always something popping up uh give me
one second while i
maybe
[Music]
sorry about that so um what i found was
is that i
i knew and it made me think about alexa
as i was having this conversation but i
knew at the moment
that i was not hearing every word that
this person was saying and i certainly
wasn't understanding all of them
but i was able through the context of
his body language
uh and the words that i was hearing to
still be able to stitch the story
together in my head and be able to
participate in a conversation even
though i knew i was only getting about
70
of what he was really saying uh and i
think that that probably is an example
of that you're describing right yeah
excellent example that that makes it way
more tangible and
uh um so basically yes so so
now um you know we are
we at alexa we're hardware to make you
know use of this
contextual awareness over the course of
dialogue
being able to carry context on the
semantic and acoustic
level to be able to improve the speech
recognition
so that's to improve the speech
recognition using the context
on the flip side there is this also you
know
notion that you know conventionally when
we talk about the speech recognition and
natural language understanding component
the interface is only text so a speech
recognition recognizes the speech frames
it outputs them as as in the form of uh
token sequences word sequences and then
passes down to downstream
uh natural language understanding for us
to be able to detect intent
entities and slots it turns out that
there's also a lot of information
encoded in acoustic
prosity emotion like uh
you know your speaking rate and what
have you
that can also benefit the natural
language understanding task
so you now you you see that like there
are a lot of efforts in building
end-to-end systems that you know have
the fuzzy boundary between asr and nlu
meaning that and then you have a direct
path and access to the acoustic
uh uh information given a turn and also
over the terms in the in the dialogue
context
to be able to to improve this end-to-end
you know
performance of a spoken language
understanding so it's really the
boundaries are becoming fuzzy in a sense
that it's
you're not treating asr as in a
standalone component
you're not treating energy as a standard
amount you're trying to build
networks and architectures that can
jointly
use context in the in the dialogue and
context in the acoustic
to do the old do the end-to-end spoken
language understanding
the other uh dimension about this
contextual evernote is that you alluded
to
is vision and multimodal
right so we we talked about based on
that a little bit that for example in
especially in turn taking and
understanding when the user are about
to talk to a device it turns out that
there's a huge amount of information
if the user is in a point of view of the
device with with the camera
that gives us a lot of information about
when they're about to start to
talking to the to to the device and that
and so the fusion of his speech and you
know con you know
visual context and the context in
dialogue
gives us a lot of ability uh to to
improve a speech recognition system but
also
building new cx's where we alleviate the
need for people to save the vehicle
and they can do you know interact with
devices without saying the wakeboard
very cool wow i mean it's i think it's
very interesting for a lot of our
audience to hear this because i think as
we
we move forward and a lot of the people
that are watching are people that are on
the developer side of things right so
they're they they're thinking about how
do i build interactive experiences with
voice
um and and hearing some of this uh you
know the idea that we're
eventually at some point in the future
probably going to be able to take
advantage of things like
um signals that are greater than just
sound
uh i think that this is an exciting time
as we look forward to
you know where things are headed and how
a lot of this technology works
because you're right there is a ton of
data in there and i know that emotion
recognition is one that is really
important to developers
um but uh yeah i think
uh just just the way that you're
describing that the way that we can
start to piece these things together is
uh is an exciting feature yeah
absolutely so
getting those you know clues from this
speech in terms of
outputting them in a structured way for
our skill developers to be able to use
them
to create new uh you know experiences
uh for for their services but also
internally we use them to improve our
core components accuracy both in terms
of speech recognition
and natural language understand it right
all right so so earlier we were talking
about
uh different languages and you mentioned
code switching when related to
hindi and english and i know you have a
paper coming out
uh that talks about handling asr in
in those instances where you have
dynamic language switching can you can
you kind of share with us
in your paper yeah absolutely happy too
um
so you know um 2019 we announced uh
and uh we launched a feature which we
enable our customers
you know multilingual customer to to
to you know uh add pair of languages or
devices and be able to
interact with alexa device in a
multilingual fashion for example you
could set your device
to english and spanish
and uh on the back end dynamically
sorry no no worries too many computers
all at once
go ahead sorry about that uh so so you
can set your devices to say like pair of
languages english and spanish
and on the backend we as as you interact
with your devices without you having to
explicitly tell us what language you're
going to be
talking to your device at the back end
we
i mean having access to the audio we
will detect
uh and classify each query as english or
spanish
so the method that we use for for for
that feature
it relies on running on you know two
parallel speaker cognitions
like in english and spanish because we
don't know what language
the current term the current interaction
is going to be about so we have to run
both
so that we cannot detect first and then
do a speech recognition on that language
because that would be pure latency
and then we have this you know back-end
service called language identification
classifier or service which which
detects what what is the vini language
and then once we know what language it
is we we use that speech recognition
output from that language and then do
the full
full alexa pipeline and execution so it
turns out
there are some deficiencies shortcomings
of going with this approach of running
two parallel asr
system number one is running two asr
systems
which all i mean a conventional cloud
they're both you know
large models is deficient especially
when you want to you know come
you know it's not very efficient but
especially when considering
scenarios that you have to build these
multilingual scenarios on device and on
edge
we don't have enough memory and
footprint to run
you have hard time running one speech
recognition system let alone
the other aspect the other deficiency is
that by virtual funding two parallel
discharge system
we we lose the ability to
to to uh be able to handle cases that
are
like we talked about their their mix of
languages
so in our case like you have a system
that is purely a spanish a system that
purely english
so now if the customer have queries that
is a mix of
spanish and english vocabulary then
i mean you have to pick one you cannot
handle got it cool
but it's that common problem where
you're not going to get it right the
first time but as you continue to grow
and learn
you can get better and better at
recognizing that so if i for example if
i had a house guest that uh
spoke japanese uh and they started
living with me over
a short amount of time it would start to
be like oh i could that's japanese right
but it probably wouldn't happen the
first time
yeah exactly and especially in the cases
that there is mixed like
code solution is happening this is even
more challenging so basically
we presented a method that we we we
propose
that like instead of running two
parallel systems
using end to one system we build a
unified multilingual asr system
that is capable of recognizing you know
different languages
speech of different languages and also
detecting the underlying language id
and because we are encoding these two
languages into one network that gives us
the ability
to now to be able to understand
positions and segments where the code
switch is happening
being able to handle them more robustly
but also
it turns out that there is this you know
shared information between the languages
that well with the notion that we call
in machine learning transfer or
transfer learning or inductive inductive
bias
biases it turns out that when you start
building systems unified system across
languages
you actually start improving the uh
recognition and performance for those
languages that are specific
that are on the lower resource the
languages that are harder inherently
challenging or we have less amount of
data for
through building this unified model you
enable transfer
knowledge between these languages and
actually you improve the perm
not only you get the code switching but
on the individual level you get
you get better performance
that's super cool and i i will share
with you one of the things that
is so interesting to me is just like i
can just feel the excitement and the
energy you have for this technology
um i mean it's it's infectious right to
think about
just how excited you are to solve some
of these problems and the way that
you're working through this
uh it it gives me a lot of optimism and
hope for the future of where
where things are going when we have
people like you working on this team
solving these incredibly hard problems
absolutely
so the other thing i wanted to talk
about because i know you have a couple
of papers coming out this year um
is the idea of like recognizing
personalized content
uh in an and speech recognition system
so
give us a little background on that one
yeah so it turns out like we thought uh
end-to-end
systems they they because they are they
try from data and they have to
do the direct mapping from audio to
output
so some of the terms that are rare words
or very peculiar
are with low frequency in our super was
on our super wise
training data so basic that would put
put these systems in a tough position
because we haven't seen enough
enough uh occurrence of those those
terms
they're not really they're really not
really robust and recognizing them
so take a contact name and your
like you tell alexa to uh you know call
person x
from your contact list yeah it turns out
people have really
peculiar ways of you know referring to
their contact names
friends and like a different way of like
the way that they format the strings and
write it like uh you know
uh write that contact name uh and then
store that
contact this put us in a very tough
position with respect to
speech recognition on the one hand
customers understand that
hey this is my personalized uh you know
contact name you have
i have given access to you that you have
access to it so i
i expect you to be able to recognize it
robustly
because you know it a priori year ahead
of time
on the other hand these are very
challenging so what we presented
mechanisms that we actually latch on to
you know these personalized
entities and the sort of in the in the
runtime decoder
we inject them into the into the end to
the end-to-end system
and if we buy us and help the
recognition system to
use these terms to to
essentially get a boost in in terms of
recognition
we showed that we we we represented like
few different methods and we showed like
we get a really nice boost uh in terms
of uh accuracy and recognition over over
those
personalized entities very cool
very cool all right so we are almost out
of time actually i can't believe we've
been talking for almost an hour already
um but i i wanted to get your
perspective on one more thing so i know
you came straight from your phd to alexa
um and one of the things that i always
like to do especially when i'm talking
with the folks from our science
organization
is to get a feel for you you know for
people that are future scientists
there's a lot of folks that are tuned in
here today
on our science channels that are
aspiring maybe to be amazon scientists
at some point
um how is amazon in your opinion
different than academia and and what are
some of the perks of
of working at amazon as a scientist
absolutely i actually get that question
a lot from
from my friends and other people in in
the field too
so i mean let me get that out of the way
first that they're both great
environments to do research
yet they they we have very different uh
you know
uh approaches and methodology to to
attack research problems
specifically here at amazon like we
talked about you're very customer
focused we do customer focus research
we always work backwards from from
customers and
and we we strive to work on problems
that are real pain points
and uh for our customers and and and and
otherwise it will delight our customers
in academia specific however uh
this direct tie to customer experience
is at times missing and we all know that
uh
you know this the notion of the flywheel
in ml and ai
how important it is to be able to uh
to to to create and improve ml and ai
solutions
this is not to say that there is no
value there there is a lot still a lot
of value for academic
folks that working on individual
problems and coming up with
technical you know solutions there but
this is just to say that how important
that fly with
ml flywheel is in in
for us in amazon so the other aspect and
the other difference
is for me personally actually was this
notion of end-to-end
ownership of the projects right uh
so in amazon probably have here we we
create usually two
two pizzas uh two pizza team that are
small team that
own a problem end to end and this is
actually just for those that haven't
heard that term before because i think
that's a very amazonian thing
the idea of a two pizza team is that um
a team should never be bigger than you
could feed with two pizzas
uh so i i think it's a it's a really
nice measurement because it's a little
vague it's a little fuzzy but
it gives a good illustration thank you
and and and to me this is very rewarding
especially for those
folks that are at the beginning of their
career
your your junior years just starting yet
you give you're given this end-to-end
ownership which is which i found it very
very rewarding
the other thing aspect of this ownership
and end-to-end project is that usually
the
problems that you work on on a probably
a smaller scale like those two pizza
teams that we talked about
they contribute to a larger scope
project
like like alexa for us in the in the in
the speech recognition
or like amazon go for people who work on
on vision
this you know working and being
integrated into this
end-to-end larger scope project gives it
has two
gives you two uh two two benefits number
one is that
you learn to think with an end-to-end
mindset
which i found very interesting and
important like by sitting
next to people that like design a whole
system into one
you learn what is that what are the
implications of my ml
and ai solutions in the service side
on the output on the cost on the latency
on the efficiency
so those are the skills that you get
exposure and you learn very early on by
by being integrated in the larger scope
uh project number two
is that also being exposed to this you
know end-to-end projects gives you the
ability to work people
with different people with different uh
backgrounds and uh skill sets
like you you can collaborate with people
people project management people you or
you collaborate with a lot of engineers
you you know a lot of managers and and
that gives you you know this uh gives
you the ability to be able to
understand what are the mechanisms for
uh for
for the that you can latch on to to
making sure that different
you know voices and different the
diverse set of
skills are heard in the meetings how can
you manage meetings that are
like uh you know uh that they include a
lot of people with different backgrounds
some i mean we are we are you know we
want to make sure that like
there are sometimes discrepancies in
terms of what what people know and
understand but you have to make sure
that the projects go
with a good pace we don't get a stall
like
uh you know we make judgment calls
during these meetings in an end-to-end
way
we say like especially for those
decisions that are not cr
that are two-way like we have a
mechanism even if we make a mistake
we can fall back to to approach b we
make quick decision
and then that that also is very
rewarding because very quickly you build
this you know uh set of softness skills
if you wish
that i found that uh they're as
important if not more important in
conjunction
with your your technical abilities and
skills right
thank you to set you uh on a success
pattern and make you
uh successful in your career path
awesome
well arya thank you so much for being
here today this has been an enlightening
conversation i really appreciate your
time
uh happy i really enjoyed it and and i
hope everyone stay safe
yes uh all right so you guys can find a
lot of the the articles he's written
as well as a lot of the other
information available from our amazon
science organization
amazon.science just type that right into
your browser
uh and i would recommend checking out
the icast 2021 page uh for some of the
papers that
um aria has released just recently so
uh it should give you more of a flavor
of kind of the work that we do here uh
in alexa ai
and you can always go to amazon science
as i said uh to see everything that's
going on inside
that organization so i want to thank
everyone for tuning in thank you for
being here
we will be here again next week uh and i
hope everyone has a safe and healthy
weekend so thank you guys all for being
here take care
thank you bye-bye